let's talk about social media today and
this debate we've talked about that's
been taking place about whether big
social media companies like Twitter and
YouTube and Facebook should be regulated
by the government to prevent what some
are calling censorship we're probably
all familiar with this phenomenon of
social media companies temporarily or
sometimes permanently banning creators
on their platforms for violating Terms
of Service and especially after the
recent ordeal with Alex Jones and the
backlash that followed there has been a
lot more focus on this issue and in fact
there was sort of a national discussion
which is still taking place about number
one should First Amendment free speech
privileges extend to major social media
platforms owned by private companies if
so at what point are the companies big
enough the platform's big enough where
that should be the case how much power
should these platforms have 2d platform
individuals like Alex Jones does the
government have a responsibility to step
in and prevent what some are considering
dangerous censorship and the Alex Jones
incident specifically prompted the
Justice Department to actually look into
this and to start an investigation into
supposed censorship and political bias
by these social media companies social
media executives have been questioned
that Senate hearings about this and
there's a certain contingent of the
public that is sort of in favor of
government intervention to enforce free
speech on major social media platforms
whatever that means and we'll talk about
that even President Trump weighed in
where he said quote social media is
totally discriminating against
Republican conservative voices speaking
loudly and clearly for the Trump
administration we won't let that happen
they are closing down the opinions of
many people on the right while at the
same time doing nothing to others
censorship is a very dangerous thing and
absolutely impossible to police if you
were weeding out fake news there is
nothing so fake as CNN and MSNBC and yet
I do not ask that their sick behavior be
removed social media platforms should be
audited and regulated when it comes to
preventing foreign influence and
American political elections and affairs
particularly because much of it would
just simply entail better enforcement of
already existing laws that are designed
to protect the democratic processes in
the United States so there's actually no
reason for any controversy there
although it's not clear that the Trump
administration is actually really
concerned about that at least not that
we've seen but as I've said in previous
segments I am not in favor of having the
government force privately-owned social
media companies to publish the content
of people that they don't want to be
associated with even if it's supposedly
in the name of free speech
it's a knee-jerk reaction to a problem
that I don't even really think exists no
one can honestly say that these
platforms like YouTube for example
aren't accommodating right-wing voices
that's one of the most ridiculous
aspects of all of this which is how
fabricated all of this social media free
speech outrages both left and right wing
channels have been affected by YouTube D
monetization including our Channel
some have tried to argue that YouTube is
overrun or completely dominated by
right-wing channels I don't agree with
all of those claims because progressives
do have a strong presence but the right
is also not having trouble on YouTube
and you might even be able to say that
YouTube is the home of the Millennial
conservative movement almost all of the
right-wing or anti PC personalities who
are popular among Millennials oh their
fame and great part to YouTube steven
crowder more than two and a half million
subscribers
Jordan Peterson million and a half
subscribers The Daily wire has about a
million rebel media Rubin report
Mylo you na police has a strong presence
stefan molyneux lauren southern Blair
White Gavin McInnes even out white all
right white nationalists like Jared
Taylor and other
do really well on YouTube and you might
say well hold on a second
some of those people have been banned or
they've been suspended on Twitter and I
think that that was unfair but the thing
is that plenty of people further to the
left or in the middle or with no
political affiliation get banned all the
time and often for no good reason and
Twitter has also received a ton of
criticism for not being vigilant enough
about neo-nazis another right-wing
extremists on the platform as has
YouTube so I think a lot of these deep
platforming processes are just
inefficient or admittedly too opaque but
there is simply not enough evidence that
the most popular social media platforms
are making it difficult for
conservatives to broadcast their message
just on the basis of their being
conservative so now that we've
identified what the problem is and is
not what is the solution number one the
inconsistency and non transparency with
regard to the D platforming by social
media companies is the real problem it's
not the fact that they're able to choose
whose content not to publish I have no
problem with that because that is their
right who they block how they do it and
why that's up to them instead of trying
to solve this false dichotomy of who
should control speech Silicon Valley or
the government we should be asking
ourselves how can we preserve private
companies First Amendment rights but
shift the decision-making power back to
the hands of the people and the answer
is for social media companies to
establish platform policies that are
more clearly defined and more
even-handedly enforced vague and briefly
described rules about hate speech or
defamation or offensive content or
whatever leave the creator not knowing
where the line is and it leaves the
public not knowing whether the company
was being impartial when making a
decision to de platform somebody like
Alex Jones and maybe some sort of public
statement about why someone was banned
and a description of the process should
be offered
if the D platformed person had more than
a certain amount of engagement or
followers on the platform we don't get
anything close to that
most of the time with the majority of
these platforms and it would renew some
of that lost trust or at least create
some transparency where the public is
able to judge for themselves is the
platform banning people in a way that is
consistent with its own guidelines and
how are they applying those guidelines
in practice
why would social media companies do this
you might be asking that's a good
question how do we actually make it
happen we have to demand it of them
right undoubtedly these companies will
have to become more transparent and
accountable about algorithms and
flagging and suspending accounts if it
is something that will affect their
image and their brand in a way that has
an impact right failing to do so if it
makes them less competitive against
other social media platforms will force
them inevitably to come along and offer
a solution to the problem that we've
identified here the first battle for the
social media market was about
functionality and addictiveness and
services like Facebook and Instagram and
Twitter and YouTube they won that battle
right but many have said that as we
become more pessimistic about social
media companies what they do with our
data how they handle things like the
platforming that finding solutions to
those types of issues will actually
become the next battle for gaining and
retaining users and that there will
ultimately be some winners and losers we
think of something like Facebook as this
sort of eternal monolith but they've
been having some pretty serious PR
issues over the last couple of years
especially the last six months and that
comes with real financial consequences
for the company
I don't think individual social media
platforms are as immortal as some make
them out to be remember what happened to
MySpace look at the downfall of tumblr
for example although it's still around
Twitter and Facebook themselves have
been having issues in terms of user
numbers especially lately and it's been
affecting their stock prices as well
social media is in its infancy and we
can be certain that Facebook Twitter and
YouTube are not the indefinite be-all
end
all of online communities more are going
to come and go and here's the ultimate
irony with all of this about regulating
social media censorship and I've talked
about this before and you knew I was
going to talk about it today it's
usually the right that's determined to
preserve the free expression of private
corporations and when it comes to
anything else like Environmental
Protection consumer protection workers
rights stabilizing the economy it's the
right who always says the free market is
going to work everything out there's a
natural incentive there it doesn't
matter how big or powerful the companies
become there will be free market
pressures that will force them to
ultimately do the right thing we don't
need to worry about it we don't need to
regulate it our right wingers now
arguing that Oh certain energy companies
have become so dominant that we have to
ensure that they adhere to their
responsibilities to the public to
mitigate environmental harm the way they
are saying Facebook has a responsibility
to the public is nothing they are
willing to say when it comes to energy
companies financial companies or any
others it's only when the right
perceives that their group their side
their tribe is getting the short end of
the stick do they all of a sudden want
to impinge on that free market and they
choose to be outraged it's sort of like
when right-wing commenters or
right-wingers on the internet talk about
how there's this big conspiracy in
Hollywood to promote a progressive
agenda to be totally realistic the
corporations that control Hollywood
don't care about anything but making
money and Hollywood makes money by
taking the temperature of the country
and giving consumers what they want
whether it's TV or movies or music or
video games these occupy people's
attention as much as social media and
it's about making money
ultimately are we also going to regulate
the messages of those industries the way
right-wingers are saying we should
regulate social media I'm not hearing
that what about the advertising industry
like Nike and Colin Kaepernick it's only
about making calculated financial this
visions to improve the company's bottom
line it's not about political propaganda
for its own sake and it's the same thing
with social media companies Facebook and
YouTube didn't ban Alex Jones to push a
progressive political agenda
they banned Alex Jones because their
brands were suffering when they were
seen as mouthpieces for an unhinged
conspiracy theorist one who they also
considered by the way to have violated
their Terms of Service which has granted
something they could have done a better
job about spelling out like I said but
Facebook and Twitter are not responsible
for the free speech of others you are
responsible for finding a platform on
which to speak you are responsible for
finding content you want to consume and
the Internet makes it really easy
there are even a lot of new apps and
websites that let you consolidate all
your social media feeds into one and
those types of services are making this
free speech controversy even more moot
and we really shouldn't forget in the
end that mainstream corporate media
companies like Fox News who are really
pushing this whole social media free
speech regulation agenda are doing so
out of their own interests as well which
is something that's often not considered
in the debate it's sort of like when the
Wall Street Journal and CNN write
articles about YouTube and advertisers
because any new regulation or roadblocks
for new media are a win for them and
government regulation of free speech may
not be as neutral as many think that it
would be you would have enforcement that
could change with administrations and
congressional majorities one proposal
has been to form a commission similar to
the FCC where officers are appointed by
the President and approved by the Senate
and conservatives should be just as
afraid of that idea as progressives
because the entire thing would be a big
mess subject to the whims of whoever's
in the White House and controls the
Senate the entire internet itself as a
whole is a shared resource and a public
square which yes should be kept free and
open and equitably available to the
public with the help of government but
not the
privately owned platforms that operate
within it there isn't enough
justification to encroach on the rights
of those businesses to make their own
decisions on behalf of their
shareholders there are definitely
problems right now with how some of
these social media platforms handle
reprimands and consequences but the
government coming in and imposing harsh
control of tech companies to enforce
this sort of amorphous unspecified
version of political neutrality would be
very sloppy it would be hasty and it
would be an absolutist response and
importantly it would be one that is
ironic when coming from mostly small
government conservatives as they
describe themselves the current
situation as imperfect as it may be is
actually more tenable than what many are
proposing in terms of broad aggressive
anti censorship enforcement and I think
that a free-market alternative should be
our first line of the fence and after
all isn't that what conservatives have
been calling for all along in every
other industry